So the answer is the first three are correct. We want to get
started programming, and we'll get started
programming very soon. The most important
thing is to learn some computer science concepts, and we'll do that
as we get started programming as well as along the way. And
the third goal is to write code to extract a link from
a web page. That'll be the first thing that we do to
start building our search engine, and collecting the corpus that we'll need
for the search engine. The fourth choice is not true. We're not going
to get to the point where we write code to rank
webpages this unit. That's something that we'll be covering in unit six.